[Applaudissements]
l'autre fait la tradition c'est toi qui
démarre tu sais c'est ok alors sachant
que ce soir mon avis mon frère était là
j'ai décidé alors je vais être beaucoup
moins drôle j'ai décidé de ne dire aucun
gros ce soir faire que des blagues
propres achats diffusable en prime time
à écouter bas on adore ben c'est pas
comme ça qu'on t'aime aussi vas-y vous
savez pourquoi jésus n'a pas joué le
match nazareth jérusalem parce qu'il
était suspendu
allez bon saison 2 c'est un type qui
joue au golf trois et un moment il va
taper il entend une petite voix qui
viennent on n'en prend pas le faire 8
pour le fait recette
sinon tu va dépasser les regarde c'est
une petite grenouille qui lui paraît
faible doute par le fait pour le fait
recette
il prend le thé recettes il tape fait un
birdie dans le trop directement
incroyable chaque trou qui va la petite
grenouille le conseil et ludique quel
club prendre à chaque fois il fait un
score extraordinaire et dit peut-être
grenouille
tu m'a porté chance une chance énorme
puis-je temps menait ce soir au casino
elle dit avec plaisir il emmène au
casino il y est fait coiffer le 18 le 18
il met 20 milles 108 de 18 cents
incroyable c'est fait maintenant près de
3 le 3 juste en droit le 3é sort lit
maintenant vrai le 24 24 qui sortent
cinquante mille bornes non 50000 bull ai
dit tu sais quoi petite grenouille tu
m'as tellement porté chance
j'ai une chambre dans ses côtés les gets
ambiante un room service qui va prendre
que tu manges quoi des verts des mouches
tu vas prendre ce que tu veux il monte
dans la chambre il commande elle fait
d'accord mais avant je vois là te faire
un petit bisou mais avec plaisir petit
grenouille il embrasse et la grenouille
se transforme en jeune fille de 15 ans
et il y voit là monsieur le juge
comment celle ci est arrivée dans ma
chambre
un petit tour pour la période si vous en
avez vous 03/06 rx et eric danizan des
airs de circonstance de l'actualité à
l'évasion en plein dans l'actu il ya un
bruit qui court dans une petit agenda on
va dire agen à une centaine de
kilomètres de toulouse
on dit qu'il ya un fermier qui a une
poule qui pond des oeufs car et tout le
monde dit wap ut ya monsieur bergé si
elle voulait peu des deux car et ça se
dit ça se dit ça va jusqu'à toulouse à
toulouse il alignera l'institut national
de recherche agronomique des
fonctionnaires qui sont des chercheurs
qui s'accroît ya bien paysans qui font
une poule avec des deux carrés serbe ou
et perpétuer ça on pourrait déranger
plus facilement c'est génial se procurer
cette poule qui pondent des oeufs car
est donc si c'est moi le genre monsieur
pgc 1 et les chercheurs de toulouse à
vous accepterez bien là pour les épauler
de carélie a opté mais si cher c'est
1000 euros mais on l'apprend ce pour la
recherche et la prennent et ramène la
poule dans le laboratoire est le maître
jolie cage comme ça et elle se met à
pondre des oeufs normaux répond
désormais tous à peine rachetée 5000
euros pas des yeux car et peu d euros
philippe est pas possible j'y vais il
arrive là bas il dit laissez moi seul un
état poule il ya la poule et tout voir
je te vas aller si tu national de
recherche agronomique
c'est l'état tu travaillais bon état tu
évoques génère et maintenant tu me
donnes d euros edit c'est pas maintenant
que je vais fonctionnaires que je veux
casser le cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe sur une plage bandés sur le
mois d'août il fait très chaud
et là il ya un an voyant qui arrivent il
sort son sac sur un gros truc en
caoutchouc il sort un un gonfleur de
plage de serre et de pieds commence à
gonfler autour de lui il ya plein de
gosses qui jouent les gens se baignent
et tout est d'un seul coup en fait il se
rend pas compte mais c'est pas un
matelas pneumatique qui gonfle mais
c'est une grosse poupée qui commence à
gonfler on va laisser à sa lettre qui
commence à gonfler de partage qui se
lève qui est ligne et qui lit mais
monsieur tanner a arrêté vosahlo purry
ceux qui jouent alors le noyau dix
années je comprends pas qu est ce qui se
passe mais s'il veut une poupée là que
vous gonflez elle ne revoyait effet mais
[ __ ] mais j'ai baisé le zodiaque tous
libres
[Rires]
sam est clé dans une grosse voiture crée
belles voitures une berline morte est la
voiture elle vient de sortir du magasin
y roule il s'arrête au feu
d'un coup il entend pas un mec derrière
en twingo qui lui rentrer dedans
le mec qui sort de la tshangu petite
embrouille ai dit écoute c'est pas
n'importe quel twingo nous avons échangé
aux voitures des métiers malades
si c'est pas n'importe quel goût regarde
quand j'affrontais un génie qui sort il
fera classe mungo le génie champéry
foire de fait caduques et nous aider
comment tu connaissais raconte une autre
base et moi je regarde pas je m'assois
un jeu neuf mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelle histoire j'adore c'est pour ça
que je fais un petit garçon voilà c'est
un petit garçon sa mère à lui dit va
nous acheter de la confiture binerie
qu'une fois le quartier il y va y rentre
chez les pistes il dit écoute maman t'a
dit de lui de la confiture dit ça tombe
bien je ne confiture qui vient d'arriver
des états unis le petit prend la
confiture c'est qu'il rentre chez lui
mais sur le chemin d'irène états unis il
faut que je bouge alors les louves le
truc il à goutte ils n'arrivent pas par
là il arrive chez sa mère du jeu mais
c'est pas possible de moelleux qu elle
prend le policier a voulu que je le
perds il sort bien c'est quoi ce bordel
lucky futur vers les arts le père il
prend le poulichet pas possible cette
famille c'est pas possible et par
énerver chez l'épicier
vous m'avez jamais un footix tu es pas
content vos concerts ok j'arrête pas sur
le chemin et connais pas le chemin par
le haut-commissaire et croise avec
excusez moi
le commissariat parce que j'ai dû manger
des impôts elodie levé ps
[Applaudissements]
moi d'en douter
marième lance la cédante uma c'est bien
celle là très mal racontée est
exceptionnel ça fait deux mois que ça
prépare enfin qu'elle sortait de loin
même si vous l'avez vu sur la pression
et tout en haut là par contre à tulle
avec un vaincu non je vais faire un
vieux michel cymes il faut savoir qu'aux
états unis on a retrouvé des traces
d'opiacés de type opium et héroïne dans
des fruits de mer à la dernière fois
qu'on l'avait retrouvée au temps de
placer dans une moule c'était dans un
frottis d'amy whinehouse savate et
raconte un truc il un peu détaché tu
vois c'est un arabe un français un
américain qui se base sur une plage y
croise un génie et le génie l'ordi vous
allez chacun votre tour lancé quelque
chose dans l'océan
si je le retrouve je vous tue deux sur
le coup arrêt sans panique au logis
lydia way mais sans paniquer tout est
dit [ __ ] c'est pas possible et où le
français commence qui fouille dans sa
poche s'ils trouvent une toute petite
tour est fait comme ça
il lance la toute petite tour eiffel en
plein milieu de l'océan le génie va y
chercher chercher chercheurs il trouve
la petite tour eiffel il arrive tout le
français les deux ils sont comme ça ils
sont sous le choc
comment on va faire on va faire à
l'américaine voilà ce qu'il faut dans sa
poche il trouve un petit peu en dedans
comme ça il jette le psy kurdes en plein
milieu de l'océan
le génie cherche y cherche y cherchent
ils cherchent ils trouvent le petit cure
dents y vas y tu l'américain et reste
l'arabe dans sa poche comme ça il jette
quelque chose en plein milieu de l'océan
le génie cherchi cherché cher richert
s'y trouve pas il revient avoir leur
avis mais qu'est ce que tu as jeté par
habib a jeté un efferalgan
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et vous
ça démarre fort très bonne celle là
alors j'adore j'adore christelle alors
ses deux filles qui sortent de boîte de
nuit à 5 heures du mat complètement
bourré mais bourré che bouras et
ludivine les tories elle décide de
rentrer à pied parce qu'évidemment ne
peuvent pas prendre le volant est donc l
marché elles sont sur le chemin et tout
d'un coup elles ont envie d'une envie de
faire pipi mais travel passe devant le
cimetière et this tiens on va dans le
cimetière quand un personne nous verrons
sera pas demain et tout donc elles
rendent la première elle s'accroupit
elle fait pitié tellement bourré en foot
bars ou dans sa culotte et tout donc
évidemment arlac sécurité sécher avec
l'âge est la deuxième pareil s'accroupit
entre deux temps lc pipira ça va mieux
et puis elle regarde ce qu elle peut
prendre pour s'essuyer le prends un truc
là un bouquet tout frais que si je suis
avec elle et jette elle rentre elle
s'endort le lendemain il ya les deux
mecs de ces deux codes de ses deux
copines ont qu'ils bouffent ensemble à
midi ils attendaient à temps il ya un
truc qui va pas là ce que je pense
qu'elles nous font les deux âmes et
l'autre la mienne elle est rentrée elle
avait pas de culotte cette nuit et
dimanche parle pas moi la mienne entre
les fesses avaient une carte amicale des
pompiers on vous oubliera jamais
[Applaudissements]
premiers tours de piste doucement au
fond tu peux y aller salle dans un
cirque mais qui reçoit des nouveaux
numéros
donc le patron et l'aspect 45 ans qu'il
est patron de cire toi on lui fait pas
le mec le gars dit écoute j'ai un chien
qui joue du piano et j'ai un chat qui
chante 45 anciennes jamais vues salesi
qui fait rentrer les chiens et les chats
tech dans ses lois le chien ou puis se
met au piano s'assied même si chaque
console via l'eau et le chien se met à
jouer vachement bien toi et le chat up
chante ne me quitte pas il faut oublier
tous suveiller dans le mag et d'histoire
du ce extraordinaire jamais vu ça de ma
vie à brel mais il dit euh pardon mais
votre petit chat et chante que des vieux
trucs comme ça où ils pourront ainsi
chanter des trucs un peu plus récents
mais d'y chanter ce que vous voulez me
dit par exemple du bon et chanter d'une
géniale inédit sans problème pour thalia
et les quatre ses doigts le chien qui
jouent et le chat a lui même
je vous embauche c'est combien numéro va
dit normalement prend 8 100 euros dijoux
donne le double je vous donne le double
vous commencez damas c'est après il dit
aux mecs il dit pas content il faut me
dire il ya un truc aussi dit non il n'ya
pas toi qui dit si j'ai 45 ans je vous
donne le double du 24 mai en échange il
faut me le dire
y'a tragédie bombe a dit ok oui c'est
vrai on vient truc
en fait le chat il chante pas c'est le
chien qui est ventriloque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque